empezó cuando McDonald's aceptó asociarse
con el Fondo para la Defensa del Medioambiente, EDF,
Es una ONG
que se basaba en el principio de "demandemos a los bastardos".
Y yo pensaba:
¿qué estarán pensando sobre mí y mi equipo?
Cuando conocí a Richard Denison,
él era el científico principal del EDF,
y me sentía muy inquieto.
Pensé: "Es un ecologista,
y debe imaginar que solo me importa el dinero".
Queríamos que el equipo de EDF nos diera soluciones prácticas.
Así que hicimos algo lógico.
Los pusimos a hacer hamburguesas en nuestros restaurantes.
Pueden imaginar a Richard,
que tiene un doctorado en física,
tratando de aderezar una hamburguesa
con dos chorritos de kétchup, uno de mostaza,
pepinillos, una cebolla, y pasar a la siguiente,
haciéndolo muy rápido.
¿Y saben qué? No pudo hacerlo bien en todo el día.
Se sentía frustrado.
Y me impresionó,
porque él estaba tratando de entender nuestro negocio.
El equipo de EDF
pensaba que los elementos reusables serían lo mejor para nuestro negocio.
Mi equipo y yo pensamos: ¿elementos reusables?
Ocupan mucho espacio; crearán desorden,
nos harán más lentos.
Pero no rechazamos la idea.
Fuimos a la sala trasera del restaurante que ellos eligieron en Washington.
La lavadora no funcionaba bien,
los platos quedaban sucios.
La cocina estaba sucia.
Al compararlo con su experiencia en McDonald's,
que es limpio y organizado,
pudieron ver la gran diferencia.
También nos sentamos todo el día en un restaurante de McDonald's,
y observamos a los clientes que comían allí,
su comportamiento.
Vimos que muchos de ellos se iban con la comida
y con la bebida.
Y EDF llegó a la misma conclusión que nosotros:
los elementos reusables no funcionarían.
Pero tuvieron muchas ideas que funcionaron.
Y nunca las habríamos tenido por nosotros mismos,
sin el equipo de EDF.
Mi favorita fue cambiar de la bolsa blanca
a la marrón.
Habíamos estado usando la bolsa blanca.
Es de un material virgen,
hecho con químicos blanqueadores con cloro.
Y ellos dijeron: "Usen bolsas sin blanquear,
sin químicos".
Está hecha con material reciclado,
principalmente de cajas de cartón corrugado.
Resultó que la bolsa es más fuerte; la fibra es más fuerte,
y no nos costó más dinero.
Todos ganamos.
Otra idea que tuvieron
fue reducir las servilletas en unos 2,5 cm,
y hacerlas de papel de oficina reciclado.
Yo pensé: "2,5 cm no es nada".
Lo hicimos, y redujimos los desechos en más de 1 300 000 kg por año.
Salvamos 16 000 árboles por año.
(Aplausos)
Fue genial cambiar esas servilletas blanco brillante,
porque el contenido reciclado era gris y con manchas.
E hicimos que ese aspecto
estuviera en sintonía, de moda con los clientes.
Así que realmente disfruté
el tiempo que trabajé con el equipo de EDF.
Tuvimos muchas cenas y discusiones hasta tarde,
fuimos a ver un partido juntos.
Nos hicimos amigos.
Y ahí aprendí la primera lección de vida:
estos cruzados de las ONG
no son muy diferentes de mí.
Se preocupan, son apasionados,
simplemente no son diferentes.
Así que trabajamos juntos durante seis meses
y esto resultó en un plan de acción de reducción de residuos de 42 puntos
para reducir, reusar y reciclar.
Lo medimos durante la década de los 90,
y en más de 10 años redujimos más de 130 millones de kg de residuos.
Bien, si se están preguntando sobre ese envase de poliestireno,
sí, nos deshicimos de él.
Y, por suerte, todavía tengo trabajo.
Y esta colaboración fue tan exitosa
que reciclamos la idea de trabajar con los críticos:
colaborar juntos en soluciones que podrían funcionar
para la sociedad y para el negocio.
Pero esta idea de colaboración
¿funcionaría con los críticos más acérrimos?
¿Y con cuestiones que no están bajo nuestro control directo?
Como los derechos de los animales.
Los derechos de los animales... obviamente no quieren que los usen para carne.
McDonald's es, probablemente, el mayor comprador de carne
en la industria alimentaria.
Así que aquí existe un conflicto natural.
Entonces pensé que lo mejor
sería visitar y aprender de los críticos más vociferantes y vigilantes
que teníamos en esa época,
que eran Henry Spira, jefe de Animal Rights International,
y Peter Singer,
que escribió el libro "Liberación animal",
el cual se considera el tratado moderno sobre los derechos de los animales.
Para prepararme, leí el libro de Peter,
traté de ver su modo de pensar,
y debo admitir que fue duro,
pero no me convertiré en vegano,
mi empresa no va por ese camino.
Pero realmente pensé que podíamos aprender mucho.
Y planeé un desayuno de reunión en la ciudad de Nueva York.
Recuerdo sentarme, prepararme,
y decidir no pedir mi desayuno favorito,
tocineta, salchichas y huevos.
(Risas)
Solo pediría unos pasteles.
Y, debo admitir,
esperaba que ocurriera una discusión entre adversarios.
Pero nunca ocurrió.
Henry y Peter eran amables,
atentos, inteligentes, hacían buenas preguntas.
Les dije que trabajar para el bienestar animal
es muy difícil para McDonald's
porque nuestros proveedores directos solo hacían hamburguesas de carne.
Los animales están alejados de nuestra influencia en tres o cuatro pasos.
Y fueron muy comprensivos.
Y aunque teníamos posturas opuestas
en cuanto a la misión de nuestras organizaciones,
sentí que había aprendido mucho.
Y lo mejor de todo, me hicieron una gran recomendación.
Me dijeron:
"Deberías trabajar con la Dra. Temple Grandin".
En esa época no la conocía.
Pero les diré,
es la experta más famosa en comportamiento animal.
Sabe cómo los animales se mueven y reaccionan en las instalaciones.
Así que me reuní con ella,
que es la mejor clase de crítico,
en el sentido de que ama a los animales,
quiere protegerlos,
pero también entiende la realidad del negocio de la carne.
Y siempre recordaré...
nunca en mi vida había estado en un matadero,
y en mi primer viaje fui con ella.
No sabía qué esperar.
Descubrimos que los que manejaban los animales tenían picanas eléctricas,
y estaban liquidando a todos los animales que estaban en las instalaciones.
Estábamos horrorizados, ella daba saltos,
deberían conocerla...
Ella decía: "Esto no puede ser, no está bien,
podríamos usar banderas, bolsas de plástico,
rediseñar los corrales para un comportamiento natural".
Contactamos a Temple con nuestros proveedores
para establecer estándares, directrices,
y formas de evaluar sus ideas para implementar el bienestar animal.
Lo hicimos durante los siguientes dos a cinco años.
Y todo se integró, se hizo cumplir.
Dos proveedores de McDonald's perdieron el negocio
porque no se ajustaban a nuestros estándares.
Y lo mejor de todo
es que estos estándares se extendieron a toda la industria.
No más picanas para esos animales.
¿Y qué hay de esas cuestiones de las que nos acusan en otras partes?
Como la deforestación.
Siempre pensé que de ese tema
debían ocuparse los políticos y el gobierno.
Nunca pensé que me llegaría a mí.
Recuerdo que a principios de abril de 2006
abrí mi Blackberry
y leí sobre cómo activistas de Greenpeace
aparecían en el Reino Unido por decenas
vestidos como gallinas,
desayunaban en McDonald's
y se encadenaban a las sillas y las mesas.
Por lo que recibieron mucha atención,
incluyendo la mía.
Y me preguntaba si el informe que habían emitido
era el llamado "Comiéndose el Amazonas".
Por cierto, la soja es un ingrediente clave del alimento para pollos,
y esa era la conexión con McDonald's.
Así que llamé a mis amigos del Fondo Mundial para la Naturaleza,
llamé a Conservación Internacional,
y pronto supe que el informe de Greenpeace era preciso.
Así que busqué apoyo interno,
y siempre recordaré que al día siguiente de esa campaña
los llamé
y les dije: "Estamos de acuerdo con Uds.
¿Que tal si trabajamos juntos?"
Y tres días después,
milagrosamente, cuatro personas de McDonald´s
y cuatro de Greenpeace
nos encontramos en el aeropuerto de Heathrow, en Londres.
Y debo decir que durante la primera hora había muchas dudas,
no había mucha confianza en el ambiente.
Pero parecía que todo se iba a arreglar,
porque cada uno de nosotros quería salvar al Amazonas.
Y durante nuestras discusiones no se podía decir
quién era de Greenpeace y quién era de McDonald's.
Una de las mejores cosas que hicimos
fue viajar con ellos durante nueve días a través del Amazonas,
en el avión de Greenpeace y en el barco de Greenpeace.
Siempre recordaré...
imaginen viajar cientos de kilómetros al oeste de Manaos,
la capital del estado de Amazonas.
Tiene una belleza prístina,
no hay cosas construidas por el hombre, no hay caminos
ni un alambre, ni una casa.
Cuando uno viaja al este de Manaos
se ve la flagrante destrucción de la selva tropical.
Así que esta colaboración poco probable produjo excelentes resultados.
Al trabajar juntos
reclutamos a más de doce distribuidores y proveedores
para la misma causa.
Y en tres meses
la industria anunció una moratoria
sobre estas prácticas de tala de árboles.
Y Greenpeace mismo declaró una caída espectacular en la deforestación
y ha estado en vigor desde entonces.
Pensarán que estos tipos de colaboración que describí
son comunes hoy en día.
Pero no lo son.
Cuando las organizaciones son golpeadas,
la respuesta común es negar y contraatacar,
hacer una especie de declaración patética
y no se logra ningún progreso.
Opino que la alternativa es realmente poderosa.
No arreglará todos los problemas,
y seguro que hay mucho más para hacer,
pero esta idea de trabajar con los críticos
y de tratar de hacer algo bueno para la sociedad
que también sea bueno para los negocios
es posible, créanme.
Pero empieza con la idea
de que deben asumir que sus críticos tienen las mejores intenciones.
Al igual que Uds., tienen las mejores intenciones.
Y segundo,
deben mirar más allá de muchas de estas tácticas
-- lo admito, muchas de las tácticas usadas por mi empresa
no me gustaban --
y concentrarse en lo que es verdad,
que es lo que se debe hacer,
qué dice la ciencia, cuáles son los hechos.
Y por último diría
que les den las llaves a los críticos.
Muéstrenles el cuarto de atrás.
Llévenlos allí, no escondan los detalles,
porque si quieren aliados y apoyo,
deben ser abiertos y transparentes.
Ya sea que lleven el traje de negocios
o sean ecologistas,
la próxima vez que los critiquen
acérquense, escuchen, aprendan.
Uds. mejorarán, su organización mejorará,
y podrían hacer buenos amigos durante el proceso.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)